Toccata in F by
Charles-Marie Widor
[organ music]
They hear
an endless variety of color.
[organ music]
They feel through the floor
the rumble of the deepest bass
pipes.
[organ music]
When they hear that,
they'll say,
that is Woolsey Hall
at Yale.
[organ music]
My name is Thomas Murray,
and I've been very fortunate
over 38 years to teach graduate
organ performance majors here
on this magnificent organ.
The largest pipes in
the organ are 32 feet
high from the mouth to the top.
The four keyboards of this organ
each control a section of it,
and the sections
consist of pipes
organized by what we call stops.
There are a lot of people in
the world who don't understand
the origin of the expression,
pulling out all the stops.
We at Yale
have sought to maintain
this organ in its original form
without doing things
that would change its style.
It's what we would call
an orchestral style instrument.
I feel intense delight
in being able
to orchestrate things
to choose the colors that I feel
are just right for any given
section of any given piece.
Another thing,
which I feel is the sense
of being in touch with history.
This organ was built in stages
and the final stage was 1929.
So, we are hearing the same
sounds that the crowd heard
when this was dedicated
for the third time.
[organ music]
The world needs to know
how special it is, and Yale is
very fortunate to have it.